mosination this is a day in the life for
Layla and I we flew out to do two
Keynotes in Orlando Florida I think
you'll dig the presentation on branding
I've never talked about a pumpkin
the first time we took a private jet was
out of necessity we were in Puerto Rico
and it was right as hurricane Maria was
hitting we see the news about it and I
check flights and the flights are all
like multiple connections so we drink a
cup of coffee and then like more news is
like this looks like it might be really
serious and I checked the flights again
all gone all right well we're going to
be here you know it's fine and then we
go to the grocery store to like pick up
some water or whatever and two people
are getting a fist fight over water in
the island people are [__] sprinting
around the store she's like we have to
get off this island I was like dude you
don't want to be here when they're dead
get back to our house and this old guy
has this massive yacht he's our neighbor
I was like oh what are you gonna do with
that he's like oh it'll just get
destroyed and I was like what oh he's
like you should be fine I said just go
to the third story first two floors of
quad and Layla at this point is just
like we're getting off this [__]
mileage she was like Charter a plate and
I was like Mindy this is like the
beginning of our wealth and I was like I
Googled I call a plane I put it on
speakerphone you need to get off where
do we go he was like it'll be 70 grand
and like we both looked each other and I
was like so we're excited she was like
yeah we're decided we both had come to
completely separate conclusions from
that number I was like so we're staying
and she's like so we're going right and
then she looks she's like what is my
life worth to you I was like are you
[__] kidding me 35 Grand to save my
life okay well it wasn't 35 it was 70.
so I call like three other Charters and
I'm like I got a guy who says he could
do it for 50. and he was like I'll do it
for 40. I called Other Guys by the way
this is the last day you can get off the
island and so like literally like he's
like I gotta call some more to get a
price I was like oh my God can we have
four hours I got a guy who's like I'll
do it for 28 and I was like cool he's
like but you have to leave in two hours
went straight to the airport and they
were like oh actually it's coming faster
we thought like these will be the last
planes out we got on the plane and it
was the first time in my life where
money actually did something like
useless
[Music]
okay
for a Guana spotting
I was getting in my car at the gym the
other day I get in the car and I have
the window down and this guy's like hey
and I was like so like I actually
announced my presence like whenever I
walked through him I'm like I'm here if
she doesn't hear me she just freaks up
when you sat in the chair in the [__]
dark like a psycho and then you got mad
at me when I cried
he scared me so bad I started crying I
woke up and he wasn't in bed right then
I go to the bathroom I come back out I
just assume he's left I just hear Hey
scream and like cuddle and then I just
start crying and then he's like what the
[__] I was trying not to wake you
like I'm awake
[Music]
I made podcasts for four years
going on everybody I am coming to you
with one uh that I am excited about and
like real talk they were just as good as
the ones I have now years not like oh I
did it for 90 days four years two to
three podcasts a week every week and
then on the fifth year it hit the real
real it was just packaged as gym
specific I'd say like my biggest
learning of even the last year to two
years of my career has been packaging
everything I was taught early in my
career is Niche down and so I did that
and I maximized a niche but like at some
point you maximize a niche and you have
to go further I always am like slow to
make those big moves because I want to
make sure I'm not doing it out of being
add that was a super tough call
September 19 September 20 rebranded it
as the game I just remember there was
one day I was like I don't feel like
talking about gym stuff anymore I can
talk about business but like a lot of it
for me has always been I'm so afraid to
talk about something that that like I
want to make sure I'm Legit if I'm gonna
talk about it when I had the gyms hey
guys I'm Alex and I'm the owner of
United Fitness I had six I did six and
then I did 30 plus turnarounds before I
ever made a single piece of content like
how you could run a gym better so I was
like okay well I've been to 30 plus
markets I had six on my own I was like I
feel confident in saying like these
things work better than these ones I
wanted to over credentialize myself for
whatever content I was going to make so
that I felt like I could take whatever
heat someone was gonna throw at me
because I'd be like well here's why I
think that like here's my evidence and I
think that approach has been good it
just takes longer I think the jerseys
are dope can I try that on
I could Rock a little a little double
double if you look at McConaughey when
he went from rom-com rom-com rom-com he
basically like disappeared from the
scene and then came back and like did
Dallas Buyers Club Wolf of Wall Street
and these other movies where he took
like serious roles on Etc I was making
all gym stuff I wanted to push myself
away from all gym stuff kale became more
public-facing I kind of slumped to the
background only thing I produced at that
point was the podcast which I'd
rebranded as the game but I still wasn't
doing anything else that was public and
I was like a year or two and then I
started making content publicly so I
feel like sometimes you have to like
give a little bit of distance kind of
like reset and then you go out with like
whatever the new kind of Direction you
want to go is to me exactly what I did
at the Q a for the VIP day I'm gonna get
up there I'm going to write all of the
topics I want to talk about and I'm just
going to like hit them in whatever
order feels good I feel good about it
or it'll blow
I envisioned a day where we have like
the shareholder meetings where all the
companies come out and we had that big
Convention of all the portfolio
companies
that'd be cool the whole theme of the
presentation is actually on strategy
which is like I'll be like what the [__]
would that mean and then I'll break it
down but like it just means do anything
get the Mustang for the buck
dude you guys are killing The Vibes I
heard the Vibes like yeah
I'm gonna briefly hit on brand it's like
if you build a personal brand then
you'll make more money from that than
your gym but then if it's like what are
we solving for you know what I mean it's
the principle it's not about yeah
[Music]
rather than do slides which is normally
what I do I actually want to draw the
stuff live with you and I think it's
more engaging that way if you've ever
seen like a math problem on a board and
it's just like all done versus like
someone walking through the math it's
different that's at least the theory and
if it sucks you can tell me at the end
brand isn't actually a thing it's an
association we make between things that
we know and things that people don't
know which is usually our company if you
think about a brand like a bouquet of
flowers a bouquet of flowers isn't
actually a thing it's many things put
together and then we put it in our heads
as an idea as one but it doesn't it's
not actually anything because if you
spill it on the floor it's not a bouquet
anymore think of a brand as a bouquet of
flowers but it's your bouquet of flowers
and what you're putting inside of that
bouquet are the individual intangible
ideas that you want to associate
together with the thing that people
don't know about which is usually your
company and so if I were to say some
things about my brand you'd probably
know that I have the best calves ever
right so that would be something that's
like associated with my brand dessert
that's something that's associated with
my brand now those are like fun little
doodads but hopefully some of the things
that you really associate with my brand
are giving first
providing value being patient doing the
boring work and the reason brand and
reputation is so hard to maintain is
because so many people want to rub their
[__] on yours so let's say here's my
bouquet then I've got this sad flower so
this is a sad face flower if I handed my
wife this bouquet all of the Roses are
perfect and there's this one that's just
wilted and dead the bouquet the brand
the perception of it massively shifts
even with one [__] up flower
and so that's why creating a brand is
much more about cultivating deliberately
the associations you want to make with
the thing you have that people don't
know with the things that your ideal
audience likes
that you want them to like too
thank you
[Music]
oh thanks huh oh yeah good different
it was great because you were just
yourself cool this used to be the first
song in my uh playlist for working out
get my calves going I can choreograph
way more like Symphony of feelings and
visuals and charts and graphs when I do
the presentation I mean from a prep time
though way less my presentations are
typically five slides per minute because
I actually think about it as like a
movie I'm gonna do a voiceover on a film
there's this amazing video I think it's
called Death by PowerPoint it was
basically just like one idea one image
that's it next idea next image that's it
can you do that you're like that's only
like 30 40 seconds and you're like
that's why it's so many slides yeah I
mean you saw 840 slides for the training
thing we're gonna do that's how you
build great training I always enjoy meet
and greets with mosination because I get
to hear like the real problems that you
guys are going through but I get to go a
little bit deeper than I normally can on
like comments or like a short piece
which makes it one of my favorite ways
to interact just in general what would
be your number one advice on how to get
the attractive talent because some
people say you want to make yourself
some people say you want to try to post
from other places I think you do both I
think it's an and you want to have all
the training you can because that gets
you cheaper talent that you then level
up but it costs time the more money you
get the more you buy Talent rather than
building it and so there's times you
spend all this time training somebody
then you realize that they're a [__]
dumbass if you were to internalize it
it's like I'm not good at picking the
right people I'm not good at training
them like because those are
controllables rather than the other
person if you internalize it so for a
gym for example writing ads on indeed
and Engineering like that or hiring like
within your clients I think both there's
all those ways you can reach outs you
can do content you can run ads like just
like you get customers you get employees
same exactly are you talking about your
store with your dad
consulting job with the government and
it seemingly fancy but yeah you just
weren't happy yeah but we'll give you
the courage to be okay and disappointing
your dad I just didn't feel like being
alive anymore for me that was my that
was my thing it doesn't have to be that
for you but for me it was like well I
don't feel like being alive and so I
like the actual phrase I kept repeating
myself was like I have to die to him in
order to live for me I needed a new life
and if that many wasn't gonna accept
that new life which you didn't in the
beginning
I just had to be cool with them and I
think that's a lot of that's like the
the journey for a lot of guys like
becoming a man is like when you start
valuing your own opinion of you more
than your father your cousin or
whatever's so it's like you basically
elevate your own opinion itself than
other people's and then you become more
independent like that's how you become
independent it was my hardest thing oh I
think I got a job I did we got one pick
one all right all right guys I gotta
head oh you're good you're good you're
good I gotta go all right
[Music]
I actually really like the Explorer
mine's got like fighting bodybuilding
it's fighting a bodybuilding comedy is
harder to click on because the other two
are so much more visual if there's just
a dude with a mic I'm like I don't know
if it's gonna be funny but I do know
this guy's jacked it would be
interesting if if images make a comeback
because I will say this when I look at
someone's their profile I actually go
only for the images because I don't feel
like watching videos it just feels more
chill
so my next book is coming out and I'm
stoked so here's a sneak peek it'll be
interesting because I think part of what
I want to talk about maybe even at the
just I don't know if I want to do it
maybe it'll be like they're probably
because it's gonna be like raw maybe
post
I'll be like how to get the most out of
this book when I look at my audience 76
of people want to start a business so
like you should read it from the
beginning to the end because you won't
have context on any of this if you have
a business lead magnets referrals
because everyone has customers the core
four-way that you advertise and then the
way to make that way better which is the
core foreign steroids and then from
there you know read the other ones hey
sweetie
hey boo boo hey supermodel
's doing her thing that's my wife I see
that yeah
I'm starting to connect with the whole
thing she's the range in the operation
right yes she is I'm the pretty face you
guys there you go what I want to do
today
talk about how to get other people to do
stuff like making money these are the
principles like I said that we have used
to build gym launch Prestige labs and
now acquisition.com
[Music]
[Applause]
your book helped me make like 300 Grand
this year so really appreciate that
again really it could be really good
acquisition.com
no it's great no that's super sweet
thank you so much man all the carnival
guys are like vegetables are actually
bad for you do you want to be a bird
so it's just you and me on stage last
week we'll just do it like we always do
we're coming
can't hear them
doing Q a in front of a drawing board
that is my happiest place
I was incredibly impatient and it's
really tough because a year is five
percent of your life when you're 19 and
so it feels like a really long time and
so the idea of waiting one year two year
three years just like 15 of your life
you're like holy [__] there's a reason
that the sayings like good things take
time like Rome wasn't built in a day
those settings exist because good [__]
does take time to build and when you
have that massive list of should Do's it
does take two years or three years to
build something exceptional and that's
the reason most people can't do it it's
recognizing that when you're 19 you
absolutely are in a season of learning
not a season of earning which means you
should be willing to work for Far Below
what you believe you are worth in order
to learn to increase what that worth is
and I had this exact conversation with
my neighbor who was 16 at the time and I
just said I can guarantee that you will
be a millionaire when you're 30 if
you'll give me 10 years I was like well
you sign that contract
he said yeah I was like okay then you're
gonna eat [__] for 10. and 10 is a long
time because he's three years in and
he's like
seven more not being in a rush is the
single thing that I would tell my 19
year old self and being willing to do
anything to learn new skills
who to hire what to hire as far as
offloading service
you're always making a trade with your
time to do stuff to get money back at
least from a business perspective and so
if you're paying someone with money to
get your time back they need to have an
alternative vehicle that's going to get
a higher return than what you're paying
them right that's the fundamentals of
when you're trading your time for money
the order that you trade or replace the
time is if you look at your entire week
of activities and Layla has a great
activity around this which is doing a
Time study make an Excel sheet you don't
need fancy software to do this and you
have all the hours of the day put into
15-minute increments and this may sound
tedious it's also really effective and
will make you more money than it costs
you time because when you actually have
to write what you're doing every 15
minutes you realize that you are not
going to waste seven hours of your day
not doing [__] because you want to get
credit for it in your own head you do
your 15-minute increments you write down
the [__] and at the end of the week
you're like okay of these things what is
the single largest block of time that I
can give away for the lowest amount of
money
Million store for excellence tonight
what are your prayers to your life
I'm gonna hit this one really quickly of
course meaning of life
um
so real quick answer for me my purpose
of life is to learn and I defined
yesterday learning as same condition new
behavior and so I think that the
majority of my life will continue to
show me similar conditions and if I can
become and behave in the way that
ideally want to do at the end of my life
then I've become the person that I want
to become and all of the stimuli between
the damn born and the day I die exists
to help shape that person
thanks
would you like to talk about the meaning
of your life
okay
I don't know a lot of the people there
were like just mosination and were not
Demars not a single questions about
chips
I was I was surprised last day here at
Jim con I've got one more talk and we're
gonna go and ask some of the attendees
for more questions about their
businesses I had this class in music
teaching everybody a project basically
just like really heavily researched one
song and that was the whole class it was
like one person would research the song
they'd play the song for three minutes
or whatever it was and then 27 minutes
would be them giving like a full report
and now that I say it out loud I think
he just figured out how to not teach
anything brilliant like I've got the
highest grade in the class did his thing
on hurt as soon as you play that song
I'm like yes
like honestly I think that was one of
the best things ever happened on Nine
Inch Nails the fact that Johnny Cash
covered someone else's song have you
seen the music video that I'll play for
you it's sick
foreign
so good dude he died seven months after
this video These are some sandals Water
Sandals I think or hiking sandals I wear
these because I can wear these in the
most environments because I can wear
these to the gym which I actually really
like I can walk in them I can wear these
in water I can wear these on the beach
they're closed toe so I can wear them
most restaurants and I don't have to
wear socks what else do you need you
many times I go to the pool and come out
and go to a restaurant after going to
the gym and presenting all the same form
dude this is a [__] Darwin outfit
literally yesterday we did the talk and
then I went to the pool and then I
walked and then went to a fancy
restaurant drying like 20 minutes yep
and these are stretchy they're elastic
it's the best everyone else's shorts are
inferior one
you don't even know about that like
yours not adaptable we get wet you're
[__] you go to a nice restaurant
you're fine I go to the gym you're fine
all right I'm up the third time I've
been introduced
[Music]
thank you
we're gonna do a cool Deep dive together
on a topic that I hold near dear to my
heart which is closing the difference
between help and manipulation is
intention either way you're going to
change someone's Behavior or your
intention is to change someone's
Behavior if the prospect knew everything
that you knew they should make the
decision to buy if you're being really
honest with yourself if the prospect
knew everything that you knew and then
they would choose not to buy then you
are deceiving them which is no bueno but
this presidential will be the best
resolution on sales you've ever heard
the worst presentation on sales you've
ever heard or somewhere in between that
is a promise Charlie Munger big hero of
mine he said we have a high moral
responsibility to be rational sometimes
you've got logical buyers sometimes
you've got emotional buyers there are
different types of people who buy in
different styles just like their
different selling Styles different
buying Styles people want to believe you
they want to buy you just have to help
their logical brains justify the
decision like most people are like hey I
can make you a lot more money they want
to believe you you just have to help
them justify hey I can help you get into
your high school jeans I can make you
look the way you did 20 years ago they
want to believe you make the decisions
help yourself Implement like crazy take
over ownership realize that there are no
silver bullets but some things can move
you closer to your goals and when those
rare acceleration opportunities come in
life take them because either win or you
learn and both of those get you closer
to wherever it is you want to go thank
you
overall it's an awesome trip above Jim
Khan it's great to see the gym owners
and our community there Jim Lords
comment below if you want to see more
Vlog stuff like this bye